Let’s summarise what we’ve learned.
The camera is a really wonderful sensor for
a robot to have, but it produces an unusable
torrent of data.
There are just too many pixels.
Far more pixels than a robot can action.
So what we need to do is to simplify this
stream of data and to find meaningful objects
within that stream of data that a robot can
respond to, move to, whatever.
So a region is a set of adjacent pixels with
a similar intensity or colour.
We’ve talked about techniques to find regions
within a scene.
We’ve use a technique called region labelling
to distinguish multiple distinct objects that
exist within a single binary image.
Once we have labelled regions, then we can
extract features to describe each of those
regions.
We have multiple regions within the scene,
and for each of them we can determine the
position of the region, the size of the region,
the shape of the region, and its orientation.
We’ve talked about techniques to measure
and estimate all of these things, and demonstrated
how to do a lot of these things using MATLAB
and the MATLAB tool box.